all right we got this story from the
Western Journal Democrat lawmakers house
raided by FBI in connection to Tucker
Carlson leaks it's crazy the FBI
searched a Florida Democrat elected
official's home is connected to leaked
materials from Fox News they say the
federal agency conducted a raid in
search of a Tampa home this month the
Tampa Tampa Bay Times reported the home
is that of Tampa Tampa city council
member Lynn hertock and her husband
media consultant Tim Burke Carlson has
been targeted in a series of selective
leaks following his firing from Fox News
last month with leftist organization
Media Matters publishing off-air content
in which he made off-color remarks we
have this from Daily Mail elaborating to
say FBI probe's hack of Fox News
computers which saw saw unaired footage
from Tucker Carlson's interview with
Kanye West leaked to Vice Florida media
consultant's home is searched as part of
the investigation
so they say in a May 25th letter
obtained by Daily Mail a federal
prosecutor in Tampa Florida alerted Fox
News to the criminal probe into stolen
material including unaired video of
Tucker Carlson who was fired in April
actually I don't think Tucker was fired
yet I don't know he wasn't fired right
they just heard a show off yeah he's
still actually an employee yeah and
that's how they're keeping him kind of
you know from doing other official shows
is exactly him on contract so here's the
crazy thing about this story the FBI
rated a Democrat
why would they do that
I mean I I don't I question the motives
of the Democrat leaking this because all
of these leaks made him look better and
more relatable
no not these leaks uh a lot of people so
right so there's two things to say the
leaks where Tucker is saying things you
know while they were prepping the show
or whatever
some of them we laugh at and like that
silly and makes note doesn't mean
anything
some of them it will just be negative
press the Democrats are going to Rally
around but the Kanye West leaks showed
that they did edit out certain comments
that perhaps they thought would be
offensive so either way I don't know the
Media Matters ones were all hilarious
yeah and I think one of them was fake I
think the one where you said Fu Media
Matters looks like a deep fake
unfortunately but I don't know nowadays
you never know like the Deep fakes are
getting too good we're not gonna know
anything we're just going we're just
going blind into the future and
yeah I mean in the next year uh the
upcoming year is going to be
very strenuous on people I think because
people aren't going to know what to
believe it's gonna obviously you know
when you hear Joe Biden and Donald Trump
you know smack talking each other over
video games you know that yeah you know
made up but if it's a legitimate
you know speech that is you know similar
to something that any of the candidates
would say
I can't imagine this time next year that
the technology won't beat every single
human being there might be AI that can
pick them out but I feel like not about
that most human beings are going to be
like I couldn't tell the difference
that's only a year and that's in a year
because think about what AI was like a
year ago was there even
excuse me I don't even think that that
we had like a lot of AI stuff that was
getting out when it comes to like the
images and and chat yeah the problem is
it's training itself so the more the
more it progresses the more real it's
going to get and the issue is going to
be the audio leaks obviously like the
video ones are kind of easy to tell but
like say if there's leaked audio and
they claim it's leak audio from like a
fundraising event like you know the
DeSantis thing uh someone could claim
that it was leaked audio and then you
know a year from now you might not know
if it's actually real yeah so uh this
was last year
I used I think it was
um I don't even remember the name of the
AI I made AI generated images of trump
Biden and Pelosi and they were grotesque
looking and very fake and uh posted them
to Twitter so they're on my Twitter
somewhere today when you go to
mid-journey and and type in Trump you
get the it's it's real it's it's there's
no way to tell it's not it's crazy I
mean they've tried they're probably uh
as you're mentioning some some software
probably could drag it down but I want
to read this though in the story that's
interesting they mentioned that this guy
Burke who's who's being rated that he's
worked for Deadspin and The Daily Beast
and then there's something interesting I
see in the story they say in a legal
letter published in Media Matters
earlier this month Fox asked the group
not to publish the to stop publishing
this footage the latter doesn't address
how they got it but it says the network
did not consent to its distribution or
publication according to a copy of
letter obtained by Daily Mail uh this is
copyright infringement
that's the that's the weirdest thing
about this they're publishing these
leaked videos of Tucker Carlson but I'm
just like
uh if we record something in the studio
it's our copyrighted material for us to
distribute and sell if someone steals
that and then starts Distributing it
they are stealing that's piracy how is
how is Fox not going after him and said
hey they stole this from this is this is
our stuff and you know we were going to
put out the best of Tucker Carlson
bloopers it's a blooper and they stole
it from us I mean come on that's got to
be a that's a that's that's
multi-million dollar lawsuit stuff well
the FBI can't deny that that's
a crime
well I mean they're rating this guy out
yeah they're probably left with no I
don't know I mean actually yeah they
they went after people during the
Napster days
and people got uh they criminally charge
anybody over that uh I don't recall to
be honest with you I know that people
got sued very heavily but I'm wondering
how does this not reach that level all
right I mean look the FBI is in has
rated them so it sounds like somebody
was hacking some
either a hacking or maybe somebody who
is inside the company was Distributing
it that's what I was going to say is if
it was a hack where they gave them
access type of thing
yeah I don't see anything about Napster
criminals no criminal charges but there
were criminal charges around a lot of
piracy stuff wasn't there like a few a
few stories I don't know I think it was
kim.com yeah that was more than just a
guy shared a file this is a guy running
a website for file storage and they're
like yeah we'll just go after him and
rate his house yeah the FBI just decided
they didn't like him I mean it was the
FBI it was the uh was the riaa or
something MPAA those uh Hollywood uh
okay yeah and then and then New Zealand
Special Forces like storm his house it's
the funniest thing because whenever
whenever this stuff happens like with
Roger Stone it's like dude you can knock
on the door like what do you think's
going on with these guys yeah you can
definitely knock on the door but it that
depends that's the discretion of the of
the you know the particular law
enforcement agency on the ground usually
they'll decide if the person is if they
consider the person dangerous or not and
then that decision is probably going to
be colored well actually not probably
that decision is definitely going to be
colored by Paul politics nowadays yeah I
think it was Tim doc was it kim.com yeah
they he actually like sued them and won
like money back from the government
because they they had like helicopters
and everything and it was just way
Overkill yeah and it's just like you can
just there's nowhere to go he's got this
compound in New Zealand you just drive
up there's like one road yeah and then
you just walk in yeah it's the craziest
thing I'm surprised they're actually
going after a Democrat on this one
though I I
I don't even think the story is that big
like of all the things that could go
after they go after this I mean this
could be I'm I'm such a conspiracy
theorist now that I'm just like well it
could be a cover for something else
they're like well pick them up for
something you know just get him off the
street they could be mad at him but
whatever about something I you know I
have I have so little faith in in the
validity of anything the government says
nowadays yeah which is annoying but
yeah I don't know I don't know like I'm
reading these and it's just like
obviously the you know the Kanye ones
are bad but you know again I question
why they would they would you know leak
the funny ones then what's the
motivation for the FBI to bother with
something like this
well there's always they could have got
a tip and they had to follow up on it uh
they arrested that's not true they don't
follow up on tips
come on yeah yeah
if you're like a pro-lifer and you wave
decide it was high level though like if
it was for Fox News and you know they
could publish a story about it
you know I've had uh what what have we
been uh swatted 15 times last year yeah
they don't they don't uh they don't
rightly care at all about
any of this and the FEDS are supposed to
be involved with like swatting stuff
right well it was it was cross state
lines yeah yeah so yep yeah we had
multiple departments we had like four
law enforcement agencies I think the
postal the postal investigative service
or whatever was involved because people
were mailing stuff oh my gosh yeah they
don't do anything
so they are yeah
yep
it's been a while since the last one
though like knock on wood
I wonder why it stopped
I I uh
I feel like that is attempting fate Tim
I know I'm like I wouldn't say well like
we've had it we have security and like
we work with local law enforcement so
it's just yeah at this point they've got
to know what to expect when they come
here since it's happened so many times
well they don't come here anymore like
they don't they don't come here like
it's a raid you know it's usually
liaising with security and then sweeps
and things like that but like the first
time they came they they were like we're
coming in the house and you can't stop
us even though we told them not to do it
and that was really annoying and then
they they made up some lie about exigent
circumstances or something like that
which is just not true
foreign
yeah the the only thing that I can see
the only thing you know the only thing I
see in this Tucker Carlson story or the
uh the raid stories is they were just
trying to get more information I guess
we're trying to pick up stuff I don't
think they even they didn't arrest him
right and they just raided his house for
for I mean we don't rightly know exactly
I don't know I guess that's it that's
the story okay
that's so bizarre dude thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time